this video is sponsored by book Walker
to say that the Issei kahshanna is a bit
saturated nowadays this is a bit like
saying there's quite a lot of stars in
the sky or the amount little sisters in
anime these days is a bit cancerous ever
since it became acceptable to selling me
sake I show a very simple gimmick it's
like authors have been trying to one-up
each other with weirder ideas that sell
itself but making the audience go now
that's no way that's a [ __ ] thing in
another word of my smartphone in another
word my smartphone again pregnancy in
another world a cicada being
reincarnated as a dragon reborn as a
vending machine becoming a super-powered
prostitute in another world these are
all real by the way all of them are
light novels you can read right now
that's how deep we've gotten I'm just
waiting for the day we get a female
protagonist it gets reborn as a garbage
can so we can have the wet dream we've
been waiting for let's roll trash why
food when a music high title gets
popular nowadays it's normally because
it's a show that is able to do something
unique with the genre something that
goes against the trends we've seen so
many times before and have a different
approach so lo and behold my surprise
that the most beloved isa KY of this
entire year would go to one that is the
complete opposite of this idea and he
Sakai they just completely embraces what
the genre is about taking some of the
best aspects we've seen done before and
drip-feeding it to us in a little
wholesome package enters that time I got
reincarnated as a slime a show about
that time someone got reincarnated as a
slime time Tensei aka slime art online
aka in another word without my
smartphone is a show that does
everything you'd normally look for in a
typical Issa guy even if the initial
premise can come off as a bit gimmicky
you are a guy who died via stab wound
this time because truckin schedule was
booked out with undead zombie idols
before getting reborn as a slime in a
fantasy world
whoa
the initial thing that George you into
the show is that gimmicky hook and the
light-hearted comedy you had an
all-powerful dragon who's a chiid
tsundere a guy whose dying wishes for a
bro to destroy all the porn in his
computer as any of us should be worried
about before we die and the amusing idea
of law XD people are getting owned by
the least threatening looking slime in
existence hahahahaha but my main concern
was what he would do differently once
the novelty of just having the
protagonist be a blue blob wore off and
it turns out the answer was nothing the
brilliance of the series comes not from
what it does to make it unique and stand
out from other shows of the genre but
from what it fully embraces from ISA KY
and runs with our slime friend is
completely overpowered with the myriad
of abilities that makes him one of the
most powerful beings in this world with
woman falling at his feet even though he
doesn't have feet acting like this is a
pit of slime you guys will get in it
well nothing really new regarding the
structure or world that we haven't seen
before and yes it works because it
understands the core appeal of ISA KY as
an escapist power fantasy but manages to
avoid it degenerating into something
cheap and trashy and his head goes down
the route of making everything so
goddamn wholesome the main drive behind
the narrative comes from our slime boy
protagonist Romero just trying to make
the world he's arrived in a better place
even though he's an all-powerful monster
he just tries to befriend and make peace
with everyone and everything conflicts
and fights are still present but they
are always used as a last resort when
every other option has been exhausted we
talk a lot about self-insert characters
in Si Chi protagonists that's meant to
represent an idealized version of us
that we can project ourselves on a while
most shows take this opportunity to
portray some antisocial nerd who
actually has some hidden talent that
makes him so cool and brooding that
people just didn't understand in this
original world apart from his little
sister of course remember just
represents that part me of whenever I
play an RPG my first playthrough is
always playing the nice guy doing the
good route I always complete every side
quest requested of me by random
characters I choose organized dialogue
options and choices that lead to all the
good endings because I just want to see
everyone around me be happy and cheerful
okay and that's what makes him the
backbone of this series even though he
doesn't actually have a god dammit why
do all these turn of phrases not work on
[ __ ] slimes
he's just such a wholesome and lovable
little creature with a utopian and
positive outlook on life that guides you
the world he's exploring no matter what
adversity comes his way he always goes
about her with kindness and a level of
naive logic that you're just always
rooting for the little [ __ ] and always
friends to succeed in stark contrast to
fantasy settings like goblin Slayer
where monsters are creatures to be slain
or feared the only focus is on different
monsters he meets who he ends up saving
that then ally themselves with them you
even have him helping a nice group of
goblins at the beginning just to confuse
my perceptions of goblins even further
oh that's another name for this show
Goblin saver I think he's a good
metaphor for the show itself cute bubbly
and idealistic but can absolutely kick
ass when needs be he is the binding that
makes this Issei Chi work even if all
the girls want him it doesn't feel like
trashy harem base because of his
genderless form so despite the fact he
can be swimming in a sea of bouncy tits
it somehow just comes off as adorable
however there is one other thing that
really drew me to the series which I
thought the early episodes kind of
hinted at and because I wanted to see if
I was indeed correct in my assumption I
did what any impatient degenerate would
do I read ahead in the manga and light
novel which were all available in book
Walker intent now for anime only people
I'm not gonna spoil any plot points but
I didn't want to take this opportunity
to talk about what the show is about
overall and why this is such a big
strength which if you've been following
the structure of what's happened so far
you can kind of already guess at because
it's to do with the village that has now
formed to me the village is the other
centerpiece of this show and we're only
growing importance as the series
progresses right now we've followed the
village from its inception of just a
group of weak goblins to the addition of
wolves ochres and other monsters while
constantly improving the quality of life
with more advanced infrastructure and so
far has been done at a very natural pace
that logically makes sense our buildings
kind of suck
well better search for someone who has
engineering knowledge you can help build
more advanced housing well better set
some ground rules for everyone to follow
which as the population increases will
only get more intricate and will form
the basis of law there is constant
growth and progression whether that be
with the village itself or the monsters
who get an evolution after getting names
by Rimmer which thank God he's more
mature than my 13 year old ass who named
his Metapod penis which was just stupid
and immature and I don't know why I
found it so funny other time I mean it's
just a metapod named penis using hundun
this also ties into the world-building
what I like about the world-building is
that the world of slime is pretty much
as grand as any sa high fantasy story
but it's done at a gradual pace
expanding bits by bit as the size and
influence of the village itself grows
never hitting you too much information
at once but we don't know this right at
the beginning of the show when it's just
a small-scale story of a slime becoming
the leader of a village hidden in the
leaves wait a minute is this the [ __ ]
prequel to Naruto eventually the village
grows to a point where more complex and
intricate issues need to be considered
and this is what I found really
interesting we gave the formation of
culture the development of science then
you have politics and public relations
to consider trade agreements resource
management the entire show is
essentially like watching someone play a
game with civilization from the
beginning trying to get to cultural
diplomacy victory and judging from the
length of the series it'll probably last
as long as a game of civilization - of
course this approach to this is a
simplified utopian fashion but that's
what makes it so wholesome and
satisfying to watch it feels good
watching a civilization grow where
everyone can work together to overcome
their problems instead of fighting
against one another and I'm sure this
could be a Turner for some people but I
appreciated how easily certain things
could get resolved instead of just
faffing about with it so that I could
see progression towards the final goal
which I'm guessing is gonna be wild
peace in that sense that time I got
reincarnated as a slime can almost be
seen as the anti overlords or maybe
they're just exactly the same show but
this is just a paragon replay through in
fact is reminiscent of a lot of other
yokai and fantasy settings the evolution
of society and politics remind me a lot
of log horizon you've again got demon
Lords you've got goblins this time that
aren't [ __ ] you've got Lizard Men
this time that aren't [ __ ] but the
biggest thing I like about slime is that
it never loses focus the arcs always
taken to a counter next natural
evolution and growth for the village
which is what made it so easy for me to
blast through there have been ISA Kai
that I like and I like a lot but I've
always found that there's been something
that's happened that's made me lose
excitement but from what I've seen and
read ahead of slime never falls into
this pit this is what I mean when I said
the strength of this show originates
from what it fully embraces from this
genre it doesn't exactly do anything new
but it's the best of every world given
to us in a nice neat little package and
I don't know if it says something that
we've had so many isa Kai's with so many
twists gimmicks and subversions of the
genre cliches that
they have in essence become cliche
itself so any sake I just going back to
being Issa kyon
feels weirdly fresh that's right we've
done it people we've gone back to the
[ __ ] beginning II sake I literally
just Reesie road itself last year when I
made that video on e sekai a ended it
with a point that slime is proven true
this season well as most shows in the
genre have fallen flat and haven't
appeal to me in any way I did say that
if something came along that offered a
fresh experience I'd enjoy then I would
welcome it with open arms and slime has
done just that it shot up to be my
favorite esa i have seen in years and
one that fundamentally ideas for the
tropes you'd expect from the genre
though apparently I'm not done with the
east occasion or just yet and I'll be
waiting for whatever weird [ __ ]
concept the John recover for surely it
has to slow down sometime right I mean
at this point wise will start a new
religion ISA Caillou's them where if you
die you don't go to heaven or hell we
just get reincarnated as an East High
protagonist unless you already believe
in reincarnation which would mean [ __ ]
are we in the [ __ ] ISA cause right
now
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you to book Walker for officially
sponsoring this video if you want to
read ahead in the slime lights novel or
manga like I did you can easily do so on
their platform via the link below
they're actually doing a promotion right
now we can get Volume one with the manga
and light novel for free with all the
other manga volumes at a reduced price
book Walker is a digital platform we can
buy and read manga and light novels
through their phone app and it's
something made it easier for me to get
into the light novels especially because
I never really went out my way to try it
out before book Walker provided me with
a convenient platform to do so links in
the description below for anyone who
wants to try and purchase it for
first-time users you can use coupon code
gig up for five dollars off which
basically means you can try to hold
volume for like $2 anyway though that's
it from me
I've been gigaku and I will see you all
next time